it's great to welcome back to the
program professor GAD sad who is a
professor of marketing at Concordia
University also author of the consuming
instinct and the evolutionary basis of
consumption
you know we've spoken about trigger
warnings we've spoken about safe spaces
and college campus political correctness
today we're going to at least start with
the topic of micro aggressions and to
have at least a starting point
microaggressions are the verbal
nonverbal and other slights snubs
or insults that are intentional or
unintentional which can communicate
hostile derogatory or negative messages
to target individuals based on their
marginalized group membership it's it's
even hard to sort of understand what
we're talking about isn't it I mean it's
extraordinary and the word in your
definition that I would probably you
know could converge to is unintentional
right I mean imagine how chilling that
word is right because it basically says
that not only if you were to actively
insult someone it's bad but if you
engage in a microaggression which is
debatable whether that's bad or not if
you do it intentionally or
unintentionally you're guilty so
basically you better stay home in a
fetal position less you might defend
someone my thought on it I've actually
read quite a bit about this in
preparation to talk to you but really
the reason I wanted to talk to you is
because about three or four weeks ago I
did a lot more reading about it and my
understanding is that the current way in
which microaggressions are sort of
interpreted and understood by many has
become a total perversion of what the
the what we actually saw from Derald
wing sue the professor of psychology at
Columbia University who actually said
did you know these microaggressions it's
not about shaming or punishing people
and it's not at all about establishing
control of speech it's really about
understanding the ways in which our
speech could be differently
understood but we're not trying to issue
a critique or punishment and even a
professor sue believes that there's been
a total perversion of the original
intention of this word I don't know how
familiar you are with with that yes with
his original research but I am indeed
aware as you said that he considers it
to be a perversion I mean ultimately
these these sort of members of the
victimology culture will find any tools
available to them
to expand the circle of victimhood and
so to the extent that their
interpretation of microaggressions
serves that purpose
well then we'll use it can we talk about
the way in which there's this sort of
bigger picture that you and I have
spoken about that includes policing of
language free speech if it's the right
ideas being sort of put out there by
that speech safe spaces trigger warnings
how would you sort of how can we put all
of these ideas together into an analysis
of sort of what is going on in this area
of culture well I think the bottom line
is you you try to find any way possible
to stifle positions opinions beliefs
attitudes thoughts that are contrary to
yours now if you're from the Middle East
well one of the ways that I can shut you
down is I'd behead you in the West we
don't have that level of barbers and yet
and hopefully ever but we can find other
more creative more westernized ways to
shut you down and we'll do that by
coming up with new tools to make it you
know threatening for people to air out
their positions and hence safe spaces
microaggressions trigger warnings and
all the rest of the stuff that you
mentioned our one strategy by which
people will think twice before they air
out ideas that might become contrary to
the to the herd mentality as someone who
I'm speaking about you here who is very
very critical of the the at least the
application of how these
microaggressions are interpreted
do you see the value if we were to go
back to Professor Susan Ridge '''l
intent here do you see the value in that
idea of understanding the way in which
comments that to some may seem
completely innocuous maybe and and in a
sense I don't feel like insulting is
even the right word
I feel like micro aggressive if properly
interpreted actually does have some
value which is you don't feel like
you've been insulted you don't feel like
the person who you're speaking to is
attacking you but you're sort of
cognizant of the lack of awareness that
they have about how certain language or
certain certain phrases or statements
can make people of certain groups feel a
particular way I find that there's there
is value in that sort of starting
premise but big picture of the math and
the manner in which you've described it
it seems reasonable to me but to take it
to another context that's related you
know the the idea of trigger warnings
one could argue stems from a very noble
quest right you know if I don't like
animal cruelty as is truly the case for
me I mean that's probably the thing that
questions my soul more than anything
well then I would like for someone to
warn me that there might be an image in
this next video that is problematic
right yes I'm not interested in seeing
that stuff as I am guessing you're not
either exactly and so in that sense
providing me with a warning makes sense
then of course when you take this
starting originally good idea and expand
it so that it becomes an
all-encompassing
you know means by which you make people
afraid to air out their thoughts then it
becomes problematic so my suspicion is
that the manner in which the professor
in question intended it is probably a
good idea the manner that it is
subsequently perverted is a bad idea I'd
like to talk to you now it's sort of as
a conversation that stems from this with
regard to to college campuses and my mom
who's also a college professor has
talked to me extensively about this she
is a tried and true leftist progressive
on all issues etc etc but she
found a very stifling environment in
some academic circles with regard to the
way in which professors who may disagree
on some of these issues are treated not
by other professors who she by enlarge
finds also are finding the imposition of
some of these elements relatively
oppressive but more by the apparatus of
academia and this could be individual
administrations these can be so-called
national academic groups and
organizations etc can you speak to that
a bit
oh absolutely so let's take for example
students there's a article that was
written by a professor I I can't
remember the exact reference but I'm
sure we could find it where he basically
wrote that he is terrified of his
liberal students even though he is a
self-admitted liberal himself precisely
because he's afraid that he's going to
walk into class utter a syllable that
somebody will misinterpret or be
offended by and so therefore he is
literally terrified I'll give you
another example from an administrator I
think this was from Seattle University
someone had asked Dean I might get some
of the details wrong somewhere I've
asked the Dean about some reading lists
and she suggested that the student in
question read a book by a
african-american political activist who
had written a book the title was I think
the n-word right we can't even say it
now what it is and so simply by her
uttering that word which was the
description of the title of the book I
think she is now on leave so anis taken
I mean I mean I don't think Orwell could
have imagined that we could be at this
state now again this doesn't mean that
this is happening every day on every
campus but the fact that there is this
atmosphere is problematic and we need to
fix it can you flesh out some of the
stories you know we're friends on
Facebook and sometimes you will post a
facebook incident conversations that
sometimes happen in Montreal which is
where where you're located and and some
of those I wouldn't really classify as
microaggressions I would really classify
them as aggressions I think there's a
lot less sort of ambiguity as to the
term there but can you are there any
particular stories that you could share
for our
who maybe doesn't follow you on Facebook
that could help to do sort of color add
color or flesh out the conversation
we're having about the way that
incidents can play out in society and
sort of the impact they have on you
based on your identity but actual truly
genuine aggressions or when I consider
fake microaggressions which ones are you
looking for I would be open to either I
mean I know that you just have have had
of the full range of experiences and
living in Montreal well I could tell you
that for example demographically as as
the realities the demographic realities
in Montreal are changing it is becoming
quite fertile for the environment to be
open to you know unobstructed jew-hatred
and so I've had several Jewish students
at my university both in person and via
email write to me saying that they
genuinely feel afraid in the university
now afraid not in the sense of they're
going to be taken and beheaded but that
for example they don't feel comfortable
exhibiting any signs of belongingness to
their Jewish identity or if they are
part of Student Union they don't voice
say a pro-israel position because the
Student Union is dominated by another
group that's hostile to Jews and so in
terms of actual true open aggressions we
are certainly seeing a change in the
landscape in Montreal if when it comes
certainly to open Jew hatred has has
your identity or let me start a
different way your identity is quite
interesting because on the one hand you
are Jewish but your native tongue is
Arabic your family went to Canada from
Lebanon as you've spoken to us before I
am a big critic of identity politics
where you're only allowed to comment on
certain issues based on which boxes you
check in terms of your identity etcetera
but because you have a sort of less I
don't want to say less common but more
implicitly contradictory to some
identity how has that impacted people's
perception of you right so I think the
fact that I do have you know that that I
and that heritage in the sense grants me
greater leeway to speak about certain
issues that otherwise maybe you may not
be able to get away with which of course
is regrettable because the only way that
we should we should we should judge
anything that you and I say is in terms
of their veracity is a true is it false
is it accurate is it inaccurate and yet
by virtue of my having had the personal
experiences growing up in Lebanon
escaping the execution of Lebanon being
Lebanese Jewish somehow that gives me
the street credentials that allow me to
say what I say not unlike how a African
American is allowed to say the n-word
but you're not and so in that sense I'm
allowed to say for example criticize
issues dealing with Islam if only
because I come from that culture but for
you well then you would be a Nazi
xenophobe I think that and we're sort of
getting away from microaggressions here
but I think this is an interesting
direction one of the most startling or
concerning elements of the identity
politics of who's allowed to comment on
what issues are at least be taken
seriously depending on their identity is
those who sort of enforce that idea
often miss that the absence of an
identity can be just as much of a
biasing influence as being part of that
identity and in the sense that for
example when it comes to LGBT rights
many times we hear from the the sort of
religious right homophobic religious
right listen we can't just do what it is
that the people that are in the LGBT
community want because their views are
clearly biased on this issue and it
seems to be completely over their head
that not being part of that community
could be an equally biasing factor and
this could apply to sort of any
circumstance that's really concerning to
me that that this sort of identity bias
only seems to go one way yeah true I
don't know what I'm going to say next
address is exactly the point that you're
making but in speaking about the lack of
identity this reminds me of a
microaggression
when someone says say Stephen Colbert
says something like that jokingly right
in this satire
he says I don't see color right I don't
see race I don't even know if I'm white
or black and then he's pointing to a
guess it says I don't know if you're
black or white right well it turns out
that that right the negation of that
identity becomes a form of
microaggression right so if I want to
demonstrate to people that I don't care
about your race right I mean if I wanted
to abide by dr. Martin Luther King
famous evict that itself would be a
microaggression so it really is the case
that the snake is now turning around and
starting to cannibalize itself on its
own tail yeah I've been criticized
pretty significantly up to and including
being called a white supremacist when I
said you know I'm not really sure if I
am white sort of in the in the
traditional sense I know that in
American culture there's no question
that because I even though I learned
English as a second language as an
immigrant from South America early
enough to not have an accent right I
sort of look like just a white American
person I don't know if I am in in one
sense Jews were very often not
considered white in the same way that
Irish and Italians in the u.s. for some
period were not considered white now
they are we know that the sort of
arbitrary nature of that but also as
someone who from no doubt comes from
Hispanic culture if not you know I'm not
a non white Hispanic by that definition
even wanting to explore this has
actually led to very significant
criticism that I find to be completely
worthless in terms of its productive
value well you need to get darker
skinned thanks mate for all sorts of
diatribe yeah I I jokingly but very
effectively use these types of tactics
against these sort of sort of social
justice warrior tactics against people
so for example at one point I had a
heated twitter exchange with some I
think is she was a Forbes reporter and
then once I saw that she was about to
start arguing that I was cyberbullying
her because I was disagreeing with her I
played all my cards I said you better be
careful and you know I'm a dark I'm a
brown person from Lebanon I'm Jewish I'm
overweight so I will excuse your fat ism
of Arafah phobia of anti-semitism of
being against and then guess what she
this
appeared because I used her tricks I
used her lunacy against her and I won
regrettably the argument using the
oppression Olympics course this is an
issue that is unlikely to disappear soon
and that's why we've been speaking to
professor GAD sad about it of course he
teaches marketing at Concordia
University and he's joined us a number
of times before
always a pleasure speaking to you thank
you so much sir